we have an older ideals that we think we
can solve those pro old order problems
with new order solutions and the problem
is and i'm again i'm going to borrow a
term from my friend aaron clary says we
live in a post-marriage society in
industrialized nations are in a
post-marriage to society because if you
look at like the rise of pali if you
look at the the statistics for the we
have the lowest marriage rate in history
right now it's like 6.1 per 1000 people
the lowest since it was like they
started taking the the stats from back
in like the 1800s or something like that
so what's the solution to all this
because well that's the problem that's
right
that's what we're talking about that's
why we're having this conversation right
now but you should listen to like people
like jordan peterson
or people like we just had them on here
or like ben shapiro and you should not
be listening to people who might not
have the best interest of women and men
at heart jordan peterson and ben shapiro
are stuck in the 20th century when it
comes to marriage they're stuck in it
because they've jordan peterson is stuck
he's stuck in the the the provider side
of hypergamy is what he's stuck in right
now you're saying jordan peterson is
wrong i i don't know his mention no
honestly i'm not stuck in that i think
he's completely incomplete how so well
because he doesn't look at but jordan
peterson has only ever really been with
his wife if you know anything about his
history and his his dating history and
everything else he's only ever been with
with with her and he has a very kind
you know i hate to say it this way but
he's got a very pollyanna kind of
naivete when it comes to
how men and women come together and and
form families in the 21st century
because he still
and ben shapiro would say the same thing
about it by the way um
still stuck in this 20th century ideal
about here's how here's how we should
get along and here's how men and women
should get together and the fact of the
matter is is that the number one way for
men and women to meet today is on is
right here
is this right here and has been that way
since 2000 it's not meeting through
church it's not meeting through school
it's not meeting through work it's not
meeting through friends it's meeting on
this device right here this is the 21st
century not to 20th century marriage do
we want to have marriages do we want to
be monogamous i do i'll agree with you
here we're better together than we are
apart men and women are innate evolved
compliments to one another but we live
in a society that separates us
completely because
women have no need for the average man
they have no need for men and men right
now are finding more and more that they
have no need for women at all so with
those as the
if that's the reality and you're still
stuck saying well you know the best
thing you could do is get married even
though contractually speaking it's an
unconscionable contract and we have come
to a point in marriage right now where
men don't want to get married and women
don't want to marry guys as it is
anyways because they're never going to
measure up to these their metrics at
this point
so
what do we do like what's this what's
the solution to that right so either
guys are just going to sort of you know
we you stay on your side of the
playground and she stays on that side of
the playground the only time you come
together is when you want to have sex
and have a baby and then she takes the
baby and goes off on her side and you go
back to your side and that's untenable
for western societies right now because
the foundation of this country and
really western societies in general has
been
committed socially enforced monogamy
whether that's through marriage or
whatever else and we're we're trying to
redefine we don't know where we're going
with it right now i don't like you say
well what's the solution i don't know
but we're on the way to finding out what
that's going to be what the
repercussions are going to be well let's
ask the ladies um quickly what's your
ideal
marital situation or everything we're
talking do you want to get married yeah
ideally so i grew up in israel and over
there i guess the 20th century is the
norm everybody gets married in their
early 20s that's just how it is um and
my parents have a gorgeous marriage and
with traditional gender roles i would
like at some point to meet a partner who
can
be that for me
um but i'm not at all at all ready to do
that anytime soon
and that's and that's the problem
because you're 23 right this is when
you're supposed to make a bet
that's how it would fix things but
nobody like i from a
i'm 27 when i was 23 i was in no way
ready to say that's the guy and make the
bet on the guy i'm using you as an
example
sorry okay don't think that you like me
um but like you want to be independent
one way that it could this whole thing
could be fixed was if women were
dependent on men but we took that away
so women there's was it 60 percent are
in college
60 40 60 40. so 60 percent of women are
getting college educated women will
divorce a man if they don't make um
you have to make the same no 58 more
makes you economically attractive yeah
so
women are like i want a guy that makes
the same as me or more which that would
incentivize me to make more because then
he would make more well hold on so in
order to be the same they have to make
58
more do you see what i'm saying like
that doesn't make sense so if a woman is
making 100 grand a guy needs to make 158
exactly here in order to appease the
woman or else she should be economically
attractive yeah she will do there's some
way 75 of women are the ones that
initiate divorce higher than that it's
like about 80 i always
it depends on whose numbers you're
looking at it can be anywhere between 70
and 80. i see 79 really commonly but
okay so but back to the question yes
like if women are divorcing men at a 79
rate whatever and the reason is
financial
and there's a direct correlation between
women divorcing men when they out earn
them
women have to be dependent on men in
order for a marriage to actually work
she wants to be here's where i disagree
completely well this is staff it's not
that one has to be dependent on the
other it's that one has to accept the
role of the nurturer and then the person
who nests and the person who perfo who
and then the other person has to be the
one who provides i don't agree with this
notion that women that come to be
dependent
would you be okay with a guy who makes
less money than you wants to be a house
husband and wants to be the nurturer who
sits at home while you're going i have
an answer for you i recognize this
biological attraction that i have to men
who are providers but that does not at
all mean that i'm going to um put myself
in a vulnerable position it means that
i'm going to be attracted to a guy who's
going to
spoil me you know whether it's with
money or with uh whatever time affection
yeah yeah exactly that and and but i i'm
not you know that's the stereotype and
there's a reason there's a stereotype
but i don't represent everybody
especially not lgbtq couples or whatever
like it's just this is how a
relationship works one needs to be the
nurturer one needs to be the provider
period it's not that women need to
depend on men and i think this is what
like the manosphere is trying to tell
women is like stop being educated stop
making money and that's not it i'm not
fully cooked yet i'm not ready to stop
and also how am i ever going to get to a
point in life where i'm meeting the kind
of people that i want to be with for the
rest of my life if i don't put myself
there
well most men aren't there though that's
the problem i don't want i don't want
those men though you just said you did
though
that's no i didn't what did i say what
what you said i want to be around men
that i'm attracted to like the guys that
you feel drawn to
they're not going to be anywhere near
your area like schooling where you're
making more i'm not no i'm not talking
about schooling i'm talking about if i
can't have a conversation about
um
politics and i want a politician
okay if i'm not in those circles where
people are discussing those things so
like education you would find a guy that
is into politics if that's what i wanted
okay
okay
what hold on you guys are not agreeing
right here i'd like to get to the heart
of the matter here what's the problem
i'm gonna take a step back because i
feel like i'm triggering and so there's
no good discourse that comes from
emotion so i'll let it move i don't
think i was reacting with emotion if
that's how you feel i would say
i will just say i want to say right now
i'm more than happy to continue having
this conversation i'm definitely not
triggered if you want to stop that's
totally fine
let me throw out some numbers at you
here um when
when a couple gets together and they're
both making the same or maybe the guy's
making a little bit more and that woman
gets a promotion at work that it that
precipitates divorced like i want to say
it's like 83 or 86 percent of the time
so if a woman gets a boost in status and
a boost in in uh in wealth that
precipitates divorce really and so
that's that's why is that well because
she's
again women want
women don't want men who are they're
equal they want a guy that they can look
up to you cannot admire and look up to a
man who is your that's why girls when
they when i say
you know do you care if a guy is rich or
whatever
you know rich i ask girls all the time
would you rather a rich guy or a hot guy
and you know we asked victoria larson
that exactly
the rich guy um
a lot of the common times they say well
i'll take the hot guy but i want him to
have initiative and drive drive even if
he's not
making money yet i want the person whose
potential who like is a go-getter yeah
he's um if he won the lottery it's not
gonna boost him
you know exactly fair enough yeah
because that's that's found wealth
that's not
when you win the lottery it you didn't
earn the lottery and so women are
attracted to really what's called
creative intelligence meaning like i
know how i i made a million dollars i
lost it and i made it back again that's
more attractive than i won the lottery i
got a million bucks right
so when i say this thing where you were
like like we can switch gender roles and
stuff my point is the stats show that
that
causes divorce and i'm all about the
babies and they show studies that prove
that two-parent household it's better
i completely agree with you i think that
um it's important that i address
something that maybe didn't come across
which is i
want to recognize that like the majority
of society uh
goes by these traditional gender roles
so there's a reason that it's you know
80 majority yeah vast majority goes by
the gender roles yes is is
biologically preconditioned to be
attracted to a partner who has certain
so biologically or like gender roles
like based on society whatever society
expects of you because there's two
different things well if you go back you
know uh 10 000
uh the women were gathering and making a
nest and the men were hunting
and the women would be attracted to them
women were working too though
absolutely of course it's just a
different type of work no like they were
working like making tools listen i'm
from israel i served in the military uh
you know in israel it's mandatory for
men and women and i still uh i still
feel that um
women can be strong they can be
independent of course whatever and they
still can be feminine there's a power to
femininity um
so to bring back to my point before i do
think that the the majority of us have
some sort of connection to that uh like
pre
um so you're saying like biological like
something
yeah it's it's in our biology to be that
way and that's okay like we need to
can i get a bottom line answer from you
would you rather be the stay-at-home
wife
the stay-at-home mom take care of the
kids and your man does all the work
would you rather be the independent
woman and your man does kind of the
female role i'm really passionate about
certain things like like if you guys go
on my tech talk you'll see that i one of
my missions in life is to try and
uh change the narratives about israel
and palestine so i would never be
willing on giving that up but that
doesn't make me any money and i'm not
interested in having it make any money
um i'm what does that do with your
family so i'm saying i'm not a person
who needs to be the provider what i need
is to be able to work on projects and be
passionate about something you want to
take care of the kids but also have a
purpose yeah yeah fair enough
you